roll the dice or go all the way by  Charles Bukowski if you're going to try  go all the way otherwise don't even  start if you're going to try go all the  way this could mean losing girlfriends  wise relatives jobs and maybe your mind  go all the way it can mean not eating  for three or four days it could mean  freezing and a park bench  it can mean jail it can mean division  mockery isolation isolation is the gift  all the others are a test of your  endurance how much you really want to do  it and you'll do it despite rejection  and the worst odds and it'll be better  than anything you can imagine if you're  going to try go all the way there's no  other feeling like that you'll be alone  with the gods and the nights will flame  with fire do it do it all the way all  the way you will ride life straight to  perfect laughter it's the only good  fight there is  you